you may have asked yourself at some
point using it how do I undo that last
commit we've talked about how a commit
has a commit ID and that it's really
important because of the metadata that
it includes now let's talk about some
ways that you can undo commits and
especially which ways are the safest my
best suggestion for changing a commit in
any way is to use git revert now when
you revert you're not technically
undoing the commit you're actually
creating a new commit with the exact
opposite changes of whichever commit
you'd like to undo this means the commit
ID remains unchanged so it's absolutely
safe to do even on commits that you've
already pushed to the remote repository
there's other ways that you can undo
commits too but you need to be a little
bit more careful about how you do them
and if you're actually using these
commands on public commits commits that
are on the remote repository git reset
is a very popular way to do it and in a
lot of use cases is the best way now
maybe not so much to undo history but to
change the words that you use in a
commit message is commit amend get
cherry-pick doesn't so much undo a
commit but it's important to know that
it does actually change that commit ID
so to recap if you want to undo a commit
get revert is the best way to go there
are other options but always be
cognizant if you're changing a commit ID
if that commit is on the remote
repository